nous voulions que les éléments chinois du
film soient authentiques et réels, nous avons donc
tourné dans quatre villes de Chine.
C'est la première fois
que je vais à Hong Kong, j'espère pouvoir revenir
m.  Style de Hong Kong qui
me rappelle en fait la baise de l'école à la maison, il n'y a
pas de ville au monde comme Hong Kong
Michael a pu tourner la caméra à 360
degrés et obtenir une superbe photo, quel que soit l'angle sous lequel vous avez tourné, comme si c'était une ville folle
l'équipage américain sont  tellement habitué à
verrouiller toute la rue ce qui est
chose impossible à faire un
transformateur d'alcool a du raisin alors y'a
surtout en Chine il y a des tonnes de
fans ici
oh mon dieu
on continue en Asie Aang Great Wall c'est
vraiment une des merveilles de la  monde,
il a fallu plus de mille ans pour construire
deux films, il s'agit d'amener les
endroits les plus incroyables de la planète à la
projection,
c'est Wolong Park, la taille et la portée de
Bouddha, tout comme bien
assez écrasante,
cela m'a définitivement inspiré à vouloir
revenir c'était fou  c'était génial celui qui est
fou